se recaudaron más de 1,5 millones de
euros en apenas cinco días con más de
80.000 participantes y donaciones únicas
de hasta 3.000 euros todo ello Para
apoyar a la familia del policía
investigado por la muerte de nael quien
fue asesinado tras negarse a detenerse
en un control de tráfico en el suburbio
parisino de lanteg la semana pasada la
campaña de goufandi fue creada por Jean
messia antiguo portavoz del político de
extrema derecha pero tras las peticiones
públicas para que se eliminara su
fundadora anunció que se detendría el
martes por la noche por lo que es
imposible utilizar el dinero de la
campaña este representante sindical de
la policía defendió la acción
es hora de canozo hay una madre que está
sola con un niño su marido está
actualmente detenido va a iniciar un
procedimiento judicial que durará mucho
tiempo y que sabemos que será de alto
nivel su mujer necesita de esta ayuda
financiera para poder seguir criando a
su hijo Sencillamente
pero es legal está autorizadas y su
único objetivo es mantener a la familia
pero un juez puede prohibirlas y se
utiliza para financiar multas o
indemnizaciones o si amenaza el orden
público en 2021 los tribunales anularon
otra recaudación de fondos se había
creado Para apoyar a un manifestante de
los chalecos amarillos que había sido
condenado para agredir a un policía el
Infinity los hechos de ambos casos no
son necesariamente los mismos la
descripción de la recaudación de fondos
no es la misma así que todo esto se
reduce realmente a la interpretación la
familia de nael dice que demandará al
responsable de la campaña en otra
recaudación de fondos para la familia
del joven asesinado se recogieron en
paralelo algo más de 350.000 euros